all right hey what's going on everybody
its bill burr and it's time for the
thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast at ah I'm just
checking it on you just checking in on
your week here right now usually you
know what do I usually do I usually sit
here my [ __ ] pajamas I [ __ ] you
know give you a little half hour [ __ ]
[ __ ] to tell what it's payday right
you don't need a full show you're
probably half in the bag and a [ __ ]
El Torito at this point if you listening
to it you shouldn't be driving but every
once in a while I do have a guest I do
have a guest and today we have the great
Joe Rogan hey [ __ ] Grand National
Champion at Taekwondo sitcom star
[ __ ] reality show a commentator right
across the aisle Conor wild boar hunter
Kim I don't know what a [ __ ]
conspiracy theory [ __ ] you whatever
you want this guy is his own [ __ ]
entity Andy as a brand new killer
special on Netflix entitled triggered
please welcome Joe Rogan thanks bill
birnes going on long time coming to him
I know
Lanza I love your show I have Lightfoot
on mine a bunch time so I know it'll be
on yours but you're a big like interview
guy I'm I'm like a [ __ ] lunatic who
just sits in the corner of his house and
everyone so while my wife walks by and I
love the style that you do cuz it's very
unique you know I've done a couple like
that where I answer questions stuff like
that but it's a very unique style of you
know you I think it lends itself really
well to stand up and developing bits to
I just didn't want to deal with having a
like book like you're fine you're simply
okay come down to my studio perfect you
don't have me but like I just didn't
want to saw what other people were going
through like oh I got an audition can we
make it four o'clock and I was just like
I don't want to [ __ ] deal with that
stuff but um but when I if you know if
everyone could be a guest like yourself
can I start with the elk thing yeah
because I am fascinated with hunting
I think it's badass I think everybody
should know how to do it and in I'm not
one of the I am an animal lover but I'm
not going to be that hypocritical one
that [ __ ] each chickens that had
their [ __ ] beaks clipped off and they
got the the roided-out mark mcgwire
breast plate
tipping over and the coupes all that
[ __ ] that you see and then I'm gonna go
could you shoot a [ __ ] pheasant or
whatever hell you're shooting out there
but um yeah i retweeted a picture of you
got this was it you said it was a 12
pointer while you say sixes six by six
they call it a straight [ __ ] excel it's
a six by six oh I sent me this big elk
that was the I've shot three out that's
the biggest one by far that one was
monster so it's huge so what is the yeah
this is the thing that always fascinates
me about hunting shows is the
nervousness and the whispering before
you take the shot Deutsch Eck okay there
it is your ass relax okay exhaling just
like if you miss I mean it's the [ __ ]
thing gonna come running at you know the
seems like cuz it doesn't I'm not to
spook it because you have to have it
close enough for you to shoot it
depending upon how you're shooting it if
you're shooting it with a bow and arrow
you got to be real close you got to be
inside of 60 yards morning hours badass
I shot one with a bow and arrow that one
out there the big one I shot with a
rifle do two bow and arrow that's that's
to me that's the [ __ ] I saw Ted Nugent
he shot a [ __ ] bear you know which I
could never do I [ __ ] love bears it
certain animals but you know what I mean
bears are interesting I've shot bears
you shot it is go get you some bear
sausage I can't you bear I've shot three
bears with my Canada back there good and
duodenal shares I bet you're delicious
you like a [ __ ] sirloin we know not
even a filet mignon you got like no
women badly tender and juicy um I've
always felt that about you Jeff thank
you we think of bears I think very
incorrectly because with the you know
what the word anthropomorphize Asian
means when you put a human
characteristics and animals like Yogi
Bear and [ __ ] like that or you make them
ride a bicycle at the circus we we have
this idea that bears these cute things
but where my friend lives in Alberta
where I hunt they literally have to
shoot them because they don't have any
predators so if bears don't have any
predators and they just breed and they
keep reading and then they decimate the
moose population the elk population and
they cannibalize each other that's the
thing that most people they kind of
handle it in-house sort of but they eat
babies that's what they do most the time
I mean babies they eat their own babies
okay as sliders
black bear sliders oh I want you
well it's brutal to see you know we've
we've stumbled across pause and stuff
from Cubs with a male boars though
that's what the ones I asked you when
you just find a baby bear paw in the
woods I mean the part of your soul has
to just [ __ ] it's got a dire cry out
like I bet something I never want to see
it's very strange I get I do have to
admit though that bear hunting is not I
don't like it as much as hunting other
animals if I had to choose like what
animals hunt you can't eat bear by the
way and that's the only things that I
hunt is what I eat black bear you can
eat grizzly bear but they don't taste
good most the reason for that because
grizzly bears mostly eat meat they eat a
few berries if you can find a grizzly
bear that was just eating berries
it would probably taste delicious they
literally taste like what they eat like
hunters try to go after bears that eat
berries like black bears in particular
in the fall they'll eat blueberries they
call them blueberry bears because like
as you're opening them up their fat is
like a purple color and it tastes like
blueberries and apparently it's the most
delicious meat in the world so without
them realizing they're already
marinating themselves exactly you guys
the lame show else Wow eating themselves
but my all-time favorite animals are elk
that's that's the best they taste the
best the best for you and gave me that
that elk me whatever the last time I was
on here and I made a chili out of it and
then the the [ __ ] health burgers it's
a little dry something gave me an to put
a little bit of butter in there to kind
of you know yes maybe you needed
something like an agar cell to make it
stick together a little video you don't
want to cook it too much because it's
super lean yeah no I put a piece of
Swiss cheese or some prosciutto on top
ah [ __ ] insane you good when you eat
it too it's a powerful food there's a
lot of energy in those is like there's
there's so much nutrients in elk it's
like way more protein dense way more
nutrient dense plus they're kind of like
with the quick cuz they're wild I know
like the human-like footprint as I said
you know acid rain and all the [ __ ]
horse should we do but at least it's it
I would like to think it's kind of away
from the GMOs and all that it's
efficient you can get so no GMOs do to
you but like the fresh [ __ ] tastes
better though it does taste taste better
I mean GMOs everything's that's a weird
word like if you talk to real scientists
about GMOs most of the time when you
talk about GMOs you're talking to
hippies and like you man you got to stay
away from GMOs you meant genetically
modified it's giving us cancer it's
terrible for the water but real GMOs is
almost everything we eat every tomato
you eat is genetically modified they've
all in all to a corn we kind of what
kind of like guinea pigs to see like
what what's going to happen sort of but
most of it is just splicing like I just
found this out recently
you know they when you buy pistachios
there's a place up in Northern
California with its da she owes a statue
of you - she's not she spent only
talking - Cemetery glad you did that
Thank You stashes talk shows and Joe
Rogan needs Anastasio I like it with T
shelled of course I don't have Sheldon
myself I buy shelled pistachios and I
feel like I'm cheating so just take big
handfuls of them shoving my fat face you
can't do that there's a reason why
there's a shell on it because if you
don't you can eat a thousand of them
yeah i buy them these big like two pound
boxes and I just pour my hands and I eat
them they're good good for you - it's
kind of guilt-free but you feel like
you're cheating like you have to crack
them I know why I stared you off course
that you saw eelinator when they grow
these pistachios the pistachio trees the
pistachio bushes are not a big strong
tree so they graft the limbs of the
pistachio tree onto like an avocado tree
a thicker stronger tree and they grow
pistachios on an avocado tree like what
it looks like but you are we playing God
that we are playing God by driving cars
- oh yeah not by flying planes that [ __ ]
is uh like first of all I thought
pistachios came from the ground I
thought peanuts one in the ground
peanuts
I think peanuts are in the ground is a
pistachio nut now wasn't joy it was a
Jimmy Carter was a peanut farmer how did
he do it should ask him I think it was
in the ground I don't [ __ ] up that's
why I want to hunt character in the
ground I'm just say our Sophie worms are
in the ground do you grow in stop trying
to recover that we don't know any [ __ ]
worms in the ground
birds are in the sky dirt yes um do I
know I mean my my my the guy who cuts
the grass [ __ ] put him on so I got
Tomatoes
got lemons and limes but all that did
was just make me [ __ ] like booze more
because I'm just like it totally got
into Kela it's like there's only so much
guacamole you can eat he just like what
the [ __ ] else can I do with this [ __ ] so
I kind of got into tequila it's less of
a hangover and dude up telling you get
all those big square ice cubes a really
nice sticky just like a patron Silveri
put that in there and then you go pick a
[ __ ] lime off I'm telling you it's
why you it's why I live out here it's
not the showbiz it's the booze well you
don't really have to live out here
anymore right especially like your
podcast the way you do your podcasts you
just rant like you could do that [ __ ]
thing and you do do it anyway right but
I also uh you know my wife's in the
business too so she does acting she just
he's doing a voiceover today and so she
doesn't have that luxury and then also
you know um she would go she would go
crazy
if if I if I you know if I just move to
like the middle of [ __ ] not I say it
lived in middle of [ __ ] nowhere but I
do when I go in the road I always have
that urge like when I go to a place and
I just start thinking about hey me these
guys riding around motorcycles no
helmets on
yeah and it's just like this look at
that Lake we got water here they got
they got they you know they got that
it's very lush land like living out here
is is it's terrifying it's terrifying
like what what happened to the water and
silver link where did they take that
they closed silver like an actual Lake
it woman yeah remember it was man-made
but the water is all gone now they're
going to develop it and dent it they
said they put it underground they didn't
really say where it's just it's just
gone yet do I fly that's one of the
things I [ __ ] would look down you go
with Dodger Stadium and then you start
coming then you see Silver Lake and then
look it down like with that parking lot
with the big top come from and the guy
was like oh that was silver like a dick
drain the water I said they put it
underground it's all like vague who do
you know when I was in I was in
Nashville this past weekend and I'm
sitting there watching the news during
the day and they just go like um oh and
folks if you're in the downtown area and
you see the police doing something that
seems a little disturbing haha don't
worry it's just an exercise and then
they continued on and it was just like
you didn't do any follow up like or
there's no more information an exercise
what are they
practicing for that whatever they're
doing is like scary now I'm not saying
they're going to come at us is it some
sort of anti-terrorism thing I have no
[ __ ] idea what it was but like just
the the kind of vagueness that they do
name it right before the Dodgers score
the other day uh NPR my wife listens to
that [ __ ] and I you know a McGee on yes
Johnny Morning Becomes eclectic if you
enjoy the show fresh air with Terry
Gross yeah there's always those pauses
now Jay when you first started doing
stand-up no one I think of I've
discussed this before but it's kind of
important you know I think of when I
think of those people you know that guy
John Ghomeshi is I like NPR but it's so
easily to be made fun of it's it's easy
to drive off the road into a [ __ ]
tree when you're listening to it to you
mmm oh yeah now there's a lot of droning
on like that relaxed style from hawk
which nobody does that really super
sensitive left-wing style of talk the
guy that was he do that really well the
main guy that did that was this guy Jean
Ghomeshi who was on CBC in Canada and it
turned out he'd liked to beat the [ __ ]
out of girls when he was having sex with
them he would punched him in the face
and clubbed him in the head and it was
crazy [ __ ] and one girl I ain't mad yeah
yeah one and he would do it without
asking him it was like you know like the
you know that's a strong move it's a
very strong move in the rack well I mean
who knows your truth because he was kind
of acquitted of a lot of it it was it's
it's because it was it was very
difficult to find but does he have the
money to get acquitted you know well
that's true
that's a good point but he was fired and
there was a gang of girls and came out
and said he used to beat them up oh wait
wait wait wait the GAO does the
interview yes looks like this bill burns
so tell me dude you bugged me one time
when I'm not saying although I don't
know what the [ __ ] he does in his
personal life but Russell Peters was on
there and he just goes like he's like
Russell you have nine cars and Russell's
like yeah and he goes why and it just
[ __ ] like making him feel bad because
he's doing well he's you know and then
Russell had to [ __ ] basically justify
it and come up with money and now I can
have it I'm sorry I [ __ ] made it
Wow and I like cars Wow yeah so what now
I'm not saying is a [ __ ] that's just
saying just this right there well even
it right there that
I hate when people [ __ ] do stuff like
he had to hit somebody if you get like
eight or nine chicks they're saying you
beat the [ __ ] out of my house ah yeah
you know what what somebody got cracked
what is your number that innocent until
guilty or how many accusations Bill
Cosby I gave in around thirty thirty I
heard the Franco but we had heard that
right I tell you about around seven yeah
no I I there was rumors of his
infidelity yes I I never heard of
rocking you never heard that no I did I
heard that I had heard that it was like
a rumor it was a rumor that he would
drug women it was a rumor a long time
ago he was there was a ricourt case that
is part of this case from I believe it
was like 2005 and that was one of the
reasons why they weren't allowed to
admit that evidence because the judge
had made a decision that if he paid this
woman off then it couldn't be admissible
in a future trial but it was all verbal
they didn't get anything on paper so
once they found out I didn't get this on
paper they're like well we're gonna
admit this and then the woman came out
and then he sued the woman that he gave
the money to for drugging her and the
whole thing is very very sorted but with
Bill Cosby I think it's up to like 50 or
something crazy yeah so you got to
wonder and those 50 there's probably
like 12 that are just crazy like he
drive me to ya know is what the fact but
the fact that he'd still be open thirty
it's just nuts
I think you know it was a you know is
one block when all that [ __ ] came out
about Trump right he did this he did
that blah blah blah it was all pretty
pedestrian sort of like oh he grabbed my
boob and then took me in the back just
just really generic
sort of lights become sort of the
clichéd story and then this one woman
something they're gonna guide the
Clintons are [ __ ] filthy who knows if
they pay these people who knows what the
[ __ ] going on it's right before the
least when this is coming out and so I
was going alright we'll see we'll see
and then this finally this woman came on
and she goes
so he made advancements at me and she
goes I just pushed him away and said get
real which is the perfect thing to say
cuz you're you're in your 20s he's like
[ __ ] 106 it's like yeah I'm serious
so she goes I said get real and then she
said he thrusted his genitals towards me
and these kids
said get real yeah and she said that
when she imitated him I was in the car
my wife we say he [ __ ] did that one
he did that one there's no [ __ ] way
that is just too specific like I got the
creeps
like get real so wonder what the
logistics are where the legality is
rather of the the audio tape like if you
don't know you're being recorded like
you know you're being recorded for a
show you were in a microphone but you
don't know you're being recorded while
you're on a bus and you're talking about
grabbing him by the [ __ ] and all that
Stevie's talking to me I can track she's
talking [ __ ]
yeah like is Joey Diaz would say
something like that and I would be
[ __ ] crying laughing and he would be
egging it up he would ramp it up he
would make it way exaggerated because he
knows it's funny he's going for the
laugh yeah you're sitting next to Trump
and he's like I was grabbed by the [ __ ]
you'd be [ __ ] crying laughing that's
why I'm just Julia Bush I defended him
on my podcast like it like I'm not
saying that guy's a great guy but a fire
a [ __ ] guy because of a [ __ ] 20
second clip from 11 years ago what's he
supposed to do he's interviewing the guy
and what you're supposed to do is keep
the interviewer happy yes the
interviewee happy so exact grand by the
book I'm by the [ __ ] yeah you don't
even say anything bad Billy Bush didn't
say anything better just now you watch
this guy at work said well when he said
to the woman go over and give him a hug
he became part of the sexual assault and
I was just like what sect there was no
sexual assault what they were saying if
he actually did it was but the whole
thing was just like okay this is just
you know I understand when we get
flipping out about it as far as
obviously just the whole they would be
them but yes what they don't know is the
way guys talk when they're not there
yeah and I'm just I'm gonna sit through
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that we've said and we
say it for fun you don't say because we
really want to go grab someone by the
[ __ ] and pick them up like a bowling
ball
yeah and say it because it's funny it's
funny and you just your target
completely ridiculous and inappropriate
yes
yeah I'll say example say if you do have
a billion dollars I what I'm learning
through Cosby and all these [ __ ] guys
is evidently you can do that and he did
say that he's going like you get famous
enough you can just walk up and grab by
the [ __ ] I'm just that was just so
absurd to me I'm like you can do that
you can't do that well he's got so much
money you got to think when you get off
that that guy under get you six grand in
cash if he buys me I don't just don't
correct
I think he's leveraged out totaled it
but I'm pretty sure you go to the ATM
and get six grand I know you're
exaggerating to six grands a funny
number it's a funny number it is funny
right I'm just saying right dude that is
like liquid rich right and your assets
are paid off and then there's I got this
I'm gonna take a loan against this and
I'm going to do that get some investors
here and then I'm gonna stick my [ __ ]
name on it to build my brand there's
that way where you're sort of like
steroid up your value but at the end of
the day it's like all right but what how
much can you get me right [ __ ] now
like I don't get that whole like well
all my shits tied up right and I got
other guys you know I'm working with let
me see the zeroes what's in your bank
account show me your phone
yes shad helicopter the helicopter on
the back is that paid off is that a
sticker but is that a sticker that they
take off and then they put [ __ ] Mark
Cuban on the back but a woman shown up
at his house and you're having you're
supposed to have a business lunch
you don't know that you you show up he's
got this sprawling estate that looks
like a castle he's got these enormous
grounds he's probably got 50 people
working just at his house there's been
greeting you they're taking you into
these rooms he comes out at ten thousand
dollars suit he's got diamonds and
Rolexes and everything's beautiful and
you're like holy [ __ ] Donald Trump his
toupees like 80 grand
what's [ __ ] higher why does he go to a
you and I did if you and I recognized it
was over because I don't think it was
acceptable back then but it's except
Jordan had to make it acceptable Jordan
made it except you may accept a full
black eyes white guy transcended wellis
curly Neal of the Globetrotters that's
very acceptable for black guys and then
Jordan was just you know everyone wanted
to be like Mike and then I remember when
he was at the height there was black
guys young with the full head and
[ __ ] hair would shave their head just
to look like him that's [ __ ] insane
he'll do that well what about Yul
Brenner Yul Brynner was the first white
guy to rock it and be a movie star
oh yeah the King and I Westworld the
original
Westworld not the HBO series you know I
tried to buy the rights to that like
[ __ ] ten years ago you did yes world
yeah I don't know what I was gonna buy
was just like this is a movie that
someone's going to want to redo because
they're redoing all these movies from my
childhood and I was just like I [ __ ]
love that movie that thing really loans
itself because we're not at the point
where you can do any of the [ __ ] so it's
still in the future you could totally
but that but they wanted like a zillion
dollars for I didn't realize Michael
Crichton book and all that they wanted
like millions and millions I was just
like all right aren't I gotta get a
flight [ __ ] 30 grand like a Prius
have you watched the show well this is
thing then the second I sat down and I
watched the show I just watched the
opening credits and I was like how thank
God thank God I didn't have the right to
that because there's no [ __ ] way I
could have pulled that off like all the
things like the horse running yeah and
those tendons connecting I've watched
the first two episodes I'm totally in
and I've already bugged my agent to be
like dude I will [ __ ] the same way
when I saw Breaking Bad I just like I
watched the first two episodes and I was
like dude I will carry a tray of meth in
the background whatever you can [ __ ]
do so I bugged him going like I'm
actually [ __ ] that's all my agenda
today I'm going to want to get out of
this I'm done here and I walk home with
my elk meat hopefully I got pounds for
I'm gonna uh I'm gonna I'm gonna bug him
about trying trying to get on that thing
and there's actually there's a couple of
actors in there that I've worked with
that I'm just like that they're on so
you know you see you see friends of
yours that are actually in there and
they're on something that yeah I can
cool a front Tate my friend Tate was on
last week's episode yes world he's on
everything no Tate's Tate's been in I
don't know 100 movies probably easily a
hundred movies has always wondered if
you know when you you're doing something
great because it's so hard when you're
shooting it and how they just all right
now his point of view would do the
master back back back and do all that
type of stuff and you just find yourself
walking around was it good did it you
notice the camera crews not saying
anything everybody's [ __ ] quiet and
it's it really comes down though to the
editors and the music and they can
either take it to the next level or they
can relay can make something good look
great they can take something great look
[ __ ] horrific well something start
off great then they don't end it and
they [ __ ] it up but there's something
weird about
having a friend in a movie where you go
this movies great oh there's tape like
it takes you out of it it's like oh
that's my friend like this movie's
[ __ ] yeah people say it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't take me it doesn't
take me out of it unless I see them like
watching themselves like I can't believe
I'm in this scene with this guy
ah that denim then it like pulls me out
but like I I buy in when I'm one of
those guys like I don't like going to
horror movies like they freak me out I
buy in I don't give a [ __ ] what the
concept is like that [ __ ] thing where
the lady was like flipping the light
switch off and then turning it on and
then flipped it off and saw the thing
again and then turned it on and it
flipped off it was right there I was
literally at home my stop [ __ ] turn
left on movies that I don't know like
the movie was coming out and was like
the thing where she's like she's like
you know when you look into a room and
you shut the lights I shuts lights off
and all of a sudden there's this [ __ ]
thing there sort of a girl sort of
[ __ ] beastly and it's across the room
so you can't quite see it's just like
what the [ __ ] is that turns the lights
on it's gone shuts it off it's there
again same spot turns the lights back on
it's not there shuts it off the third
time and it's right in a [ __ ] grill
hmm yeah scared the [ __ ] out of me
some layer which Blair Witch when they
were going through the movie didn't skim
it Ralphie may go do didn't [ __ ] scam
the movie scare the [ __ ] out of me I saw
that movie by myself I'd done a spot at
the Laugh Factory I went down to Mann's
Chinese Theater though the one that
galley would galaxy I think that's still
there anymore right next door and I saw
like the midnight showing by myself dude
freaked those are the inner yeah but
nobody I knew and it was like really
sort of like there wasn't a lot of
people there then that walked through
the parking garage oh dude I was [ __ ]
I was freaked I saw that movie in
Houston Texas Chris mcgahren I did a
show we did a show at the old laugh stop
you ever do the old laughs stop ROK's ah
did I do that one Drake Club I think I
just might whatever the classic one was
that Hicks and all those guys it had
just moved to the new spawn spot sucked
the new spot was not good but the old
spot was amazing and that's where I did
my first album that was I'm gonna be
dead someday I did in 1999 hmm we we did
a show and then McGwire and I met these
kids that worked across the street at
the movie theater and they
you guys we have the keys to the movie
theater you guys want to go watch the
Blair Witch just us we're like holy [ __ ]
let's do it
yeah so we left we had a 10 o'clock show
it's like midnight we go across the
street they [ __ ] cook up the popcorn
the whole deal gave us free salsa
lock the door you could even do that
today no it was amazing I mean today
everything's digital you know the kid
spools up the [ __ ] the reel and
everything like that and we sat down in
a theater it was like three of them and
two of us and we watched the Blair Witch
and [ __ ] our pants it was awesome oh my
god Josh screaming I still remember that
when the kids stare in the corner whoo
oh yeah when they just sort of like went
past it yeah all of that [ __ ] where
rather than just showing you saw and
somebody's head off just the idea yeah
when you think of like Tarantino talked
about that were in Reservoir Dogs
he had one scene where they showed the
guy hack in the ear off versus just
panning away and hearing the guy scream
and it's just like it was way more
[ __ ] disturbing that that ruined that
song for me for a long time I yeah what
song was that Marvin Nash screaming um
now here Stephen Wright's voice uh well
I don't know we film oh yeah I'm Ryan
and anything whoa yeah that was that
said something today
stop stop remember that when he did he
threw yeah right adding a fun song to a
horrific scene oh that was so the
powerlessness of just [ __ ] I can't I
can't I can't deal with that's like
Scarface Myra Scarface when they cut the
guy up with a chainsaw he's tied up in
the in the bathtub and they forced Tony
Montana to watch he's getting splattered
with blood as a hack his friend up yeah
no yes habits my mother took us to see
that she didn't know what it was
took all of us to see it and my youngest
brother was like nine I think and and if
my mother said after this chainsaw scene
we have to get out of here I would have
been like fine because I'm in watch
cycle it was really I asked my mother
years later she was just like well yeah
I thought at that point yes that it
might have been a little mature this is
the signature mature for your youngest
brother and
but I was laughing I was going yeah but
you always took us to cool movie she
goes and she goes yeah she goes that was
a good move she goes on taking those
stupid things like she was against like
the whole she took us to full of a
Benjie and Herbie goes to Monte Carlo
and then that my parents were just like
we're not [ __ ] sitting through this
[ __ ] we're gonna go to a movie that
we're going to enjoy too and then I went
from that to like stripes and like Scott
your parents just and [ __ ] me I just
said [ __ ] it let her go 'no go out we're
gonna go there yeah we're gonna see some
dick but let's leave me I'm sweating
like a pig you turn the AC on yeah let's
uh let's get to UM let's get to what I
wanted to promote here you got your
stand-up special triggered coming up so
first I'll oh yeah sorry about all right
ready
when is it uh when is it airing I don't
I was handing them I saying where did
you shoot it got it this is not bad as
an interview how bad - I'm trying to
think of what I'm supposed to ask you
San Francisco - Fillmore
I want you it yeah I wanted to do it at
a comedy club and there was like a
debate between Netflix and me Netflix
want to do it at a huge place I wanted
to do it at a tiny place because I did
my last one at the Comedy Works in
Denver which is only like a couple
hundred people and I like that I think
there's something about when you're
sitting in a living room and you're
sitting on the couch you watch a comedy
special it lends itself better to being
in a like a club when you're filming it
it feels more intimate you know I see
like you're on top of the crowd it's
more like what it would be like the
environment that it would be so we made
a compromise we did the film or theater
which is a [ __ ] really cool theater
and it's only 450 seats it's pretty
small it's got a high ceiling and it's
kind of a big stage and everything that
but it's fairly small place but that's
cool but next one I'm gonna do in a
small place I think I think I might do
it the store new as funny is when I went
to go do mine at the Tabernacle you had
already been there and did one so I was
like how am I gonna make this different
and I did the film or in 2009 let it go
I did there did you yeah so I think
we're blessed we go Mithila going back
and wait you doing your new one yeah uh
I did it last Friday you did it yep I
did it at the Ryman in Nashville dude I
was just there I [ __ ] love that play
place is crazy they used to do the Grand
Ole Opry yes Cedric the Entertainer just
did one there so I watched like the
opening to his just to see because I was
like because then you got to kind of
disguise it so it doesn't look like oh
my god he's at the exact same [ __ ]
place and sex you know that guy's huge
so I wanted to make sure I was like
alright well we gotta try to you know he
came in with a whole marching band and
all that which is the exact opposite to
my style so I was like okay cool
Katt Williams brought a lion he brought
a lion onstage that's awesome I love
that guy that guy's [ __ ] lawyers he's
finally funniest guys alive and you know
and today gets lols to go on stage with
a [ __ ] lion is hilarious how do you
come by one I wish I was in that [ __ ]
pitch meeting my guy mrs. D lace what's
the concept I'm coming on stage with a
lion a lion in a cage like a stuff for
now real one
he got so sweaty during his special here
to stop and change clothes is that right
yeah you literally stopped is a I'll be
right back went backstage change his
[ __ ] clothes drenched I mean it's
completely smooth what is if they point
they put that HD makeup on and then
there's all those lights on you yeah and
then then you're going hard yeah cuz
it's your special and you really want to
make sure you're going to get a good one
and then if the [ __ ] AC is a little
messed up yeah give the crowds all
[ __ ] packed in in the wrong venue
yeah you can get yourself into a
situation I don't wear makeup on those
things I wouldn't wear for Comedy
Central I don't wear it for the UFC I
don't worry for anything just like I
don't this is what I look like
yeah I think it's good it came first of
all from Fear Factor when I first start
doing Fear Factor they wanted they put
like a little anti shine on me a little
this a little that and after a while I'm
like look these [ __ ] people are
covered in blood I mean they've got dirt
all over their face and I'm sitting
there with makeup on you have to touch
me up in between scenes you know
ridiculous that is yes and then we would
go from that to the UFC where people
were literally their faces getting
busted open their get giant [ __ ]
funnies I never noticed like when I
watch you in the UFC I never noticed
like oh wow like he can he want a TV
without makeup that's so brave that's
such a courageous thing I you just you
look like you well that's what I look
like you know I'm just like I'm not you
know my Goldberg gets it they spray it
on the
like an airbrush I'm not kidding there's
an airbrush they do it to everybody all
the ring girls and everything the
airbrush them that's what they'd I
didn't go that fight I put up to my
giant forehead I gotta get something for
it how dude I got you beat dude do you
know wait guys he's not the same way
classes went on a crazy on stage I sweat
like crazy I mean my last special I
looked at it when I was doing the
editing I'm like Jesus I'm sweaty [ __ ]
like it just looks ridiculous looks like
I'm like I'm on drugs yeah but you're up
there working and you're not like just
staying there so yeah this one I I
didn't have any this last night I made
sure the a/c was cranked like with each
special I learned something yeah so I
was like make sure the eight you know
the ACS cranked don't [ __ ] cake the
makeup on or whatever just so it was
just a little bit of that that's that's
all those stupid little [ __ ] things
you know don't stick my parents in the
front row please thank them is just
beyond beyond beyond the pale yeah and I
I don't show any audience any more that
I decided no more audience I never did
yeah that's the way to go no audience
shots and everything kind of mostly from
the waist up unless you need to see my
legs for like a particular thing I'm
doing yeah I want to go give away all
your secrets because of it because now I
feel like because there's so many
specials coming out so many [ __ ]
specials coming out that uh you know
that then it becomes like you you have
to have like whatever you'll look is you
know what I mean I mean to think of it
as you have such a great act that's
going to stand on anyways but if you can
add like your own sort of style the way
you shoot them that becomes part of your
thing that's another way to try to get
it out because you get on Netflix with
the specials dude you just yeah you
[ __ ] scroll and scroll and scroll and
scrolling um I guess so I just wanted it
to be like you're watching it like no
cutaways
I don't want cutting to the left cut
into the right cutting for no reason
like like there was a director that I
work with once it was like you know we'd
have to cut to the audience you know
that's how we're gonna do our edits I go
let's just try to do with no edits just
we can't of course we can if I do a good
show we could do with no edits he was
like no look trust me we're gonna do
this I'm like no this is my [ __ ]
special I don't even know you
yeah like you're coming in here and you
wanted to do all this stupid [ __ ] and
film the crowd and you know the people
want to know that people are laughing
like they're going to hear them laughing
like it takes it in my opinion it takes
you out of it
Bill Cosby himself oh yeah perfectly
sits down for like an hour and 40
minutes killing they never they never go
to the crowd the background just slowly
changes different colors and guy
absolutely murdered you and I were
supposed to go see Bill Cosby in Vegas
we had made like it we were talking
about doing it but we both flaked and we
never wound up doing it and that's one
of my main regrets this day I would have
liked to see him before the stink hit
him I did I saw it right before I met
him and then three months later I saw
him remember when he was doing shows
still like all those women were coming
out he was still doing shows like he was
still doing shows he was like [ __ ] it
I'm still doing them and he went out and
he still did those shows for a little
while I think I think he thought he was
powerful enough to just sort of ignore
it and then it wasn't gonna it wasn't
going to come around but dude I got to
tell you if you gave me a thousand
guests not a thousand but if you gave me
two hundred guesses his name would not
be on that out of all the [ __ ] of all
the [ __ ] people like if you said okay
this there's a comic out there doing
this [ __ ] really you got your top 20
will you'd be like oh yeah you know what
why did I never heard the rumors I did
hear the rumors and also there was a
time my not in the clubhouse how am i a
comedian this long and I'm not [ __ ]
here in the rumors I heard it from
Hollywood people I didn't hear it from
comics I heard people in the business I
heard it from like actors and from
people that like work on TV show sets I
heard it during the news radio days I
had heard it yeah I was doing it at the
show he was doing it other people that
were on the show I don't to two people
up allegedly who the [ __ ] knows but
there's something with it was something
unbelievable
unbelievably creepy but after the
accusations came out when he was still
doing shows he would go on stage with
one eye looking to the left one eye
looking straight he developed a dead eye
somewhere along the line right so he'd
go on stage with that weird kind of some
slack he's like 90 I know I'm famous by
the grace of God but he's dying right
and that's my point is like things are
falling off the wheels right the wheels
are falling off the ride and he's got
this shirt on this sweater on it says
hello friend and he's on stage and he
walks out there and in
and everybody's clapping and cheering
and some guys Jana you're a rapist you
are a rapist and then you know they grab
the guy and shuffle him out and then
people don't we love you bill and he
just doesn't even acknowledge that just
ignore them just ignore them yeah it was
something crazy about that it was like
the last the last sparks before they
threw the water on the fires like there
was just a little hope like a gas you
got some embers blast spark before they
took the gas Rumi
I mean his career I mean Eva's life they
threw water on him like I mean he's just
it's over
like no one's gonna go see him live now
right I mean it's kind of over I'm
doesn't water put out the sparks yes
that's what I mean it through the water
on him they said when that man they
saved it
yeah no I mean like you had a moment of
like there was still some sparks okay I
play the accusations came out but he was
still doing these shows and people still
came out doors we love you bill he's got
these lean analogies to me she I'm not
I'm not the brightest it wasn't a good
analogy I what your analogies probably
better you know the blowing the flames
on the fire it's like we almost had it
out like it was almost dude you know my
last flight sort of caught on fire
wise helicopter flight no no no airplane
jet yeah back from my special Nashville
to LA and we got up to cruising altitude
it smelled like burnt popcorn so I was
like the the stewardess is like well
fast-forward through this was it--
already told him I think I was like did
they burn the [ __ ] meal or something
and then it sort of went away then it
kind of came back and I felt this with
everybody had the shades pulled down I
felt like we were starting to descend
and then it felt really like I felt like
the wing shaken and [ __ ] and I was like
oh wow man like there must be some
turbulence I thought it was just
descending to go underneath it then go
back up again like it get a little bit
smoother air here sorry about the movie
right if there's gonna be doing that
[ __ ] never said a [ __ ] word and then
all of a sudden like my drink that was
in the late little middle armrest
started sliding forward like it was
gonna fall to the floor I'm like oh [ __ ]
and then the stewardess came oh she goes
yeah we're gonna be landing here shortly
so I have to take those drinks right and
then the woman next to me she landed
premature oh yeah we've only 50 minutes
into the flight from Nashville to LA my
favorite thing was a woman actually
takes a headphones off she say
ready let me just [ __ ] tell we were
on the Concorde I was like no I was on
fire I don't know I don't know what it
was I was thinking like I'll [ __ ] it's
it's gonna be something in somebody's
bag like the luggages [ __ ] some [ __ ]
like that valujet something caught on
fire underneath there and like my whole
thing was when we're going down I wasn't
nervous because he had full control of
the plane maneuvering and all that I
just knew like yeah if you smell smoke
that is a the procedure is land
immediately so that's what he's doing
and we're 30,000 feet up so he's going
to land quickly that's the shaking
that's fine I feel it's making turns and
banks everything's working but my whole
thing is you know I don't know anything
about planes but I'm just like if it
burns through the wrong wire if the
hydraulics like what the [ __ ] gonna
happen so yeah we came in to a landing
in Little Rock and we came in like over
this river and I couldn't see the runway
oh you can't see straight so I'm just on
that sign I just see this [ __ ] River
seem to be following it that's something
like he's gonna Sully this thing and
[ __ ] send us into the water Jesus um
and I was already thinking you know
what's gonna happen the front part of
the plane is gonna get [ __ ] up so that
doors not going to open something
[ __ ] fight past these first-class
people into coach you know what I mean
we're real people work so they're gonna
be sounding and outmuscle me as they get
through this I'm gonna be [ __ ] if we
use the first-class though I can take
out the chick next to me and a lot of
people going to be unconscious anyway
and just from the stress and the impact
do you know was uh was hilarious was the
the woman across the Alpha me was
totally freaking out because
unfortunately her dad I guess had died
in a plane crash
so she was totally like like totally
[ __ ] hyperventilating - the point was
making me angry like how [ __ ] freaked
out she was what kills me is she's told
she's totally freaking out about that
but I swear to god dude like ten minutes
earlier barefoot walked in used the
bathroom and came back out like like
that doesn't scare her that doesn't
scare her but a [ __ ] a couple of
lights on in the cockpit you know and
the smell of burnt popcorn now she's
freaking out barefoot
what the [ __ ] everyone in the bathroom
is is a new thing I've been flying for
20 years I've never seen it it started
it with socks and now it's flux are even
[ __ ] worse he's like you absorb it
but whatever happened to women were they
decided to wear shoes that hurt
like what if they always have but what
the [ __ ] is that about that is because
of their lack of power uh they couldnt
get a good job you know I mean believe
me if it would switch the other way if
you made a doll less an hour eye you
couldn't imagine the shoes you'd be
wearing right now ja ja that's enough do
you know that that's not true do you
know that that whole thing about the the
the gender disparity the wage gap is not
true do you know what that actually is
it's choices and jobs it's not job for
job like if you were an engineer you
working next to a woman she wouldn't be
making 70 cents to your dollar it's
[ __ ] it's a lie and it's one of
those propaganda things that they like
to tout and you heard [ __ ] Obama talk
about it Sarah Silverman talked about it
when she was trying to get Hillary
Clinton elected it's a it's a weird
thing that people keep her plenty but
she was not Bernie Sanders I thought
Sarah Sylvan was with Hillary Clinton I
thought it was initially Bernie Sanders
then everybody show us then everybody
jumped ship in one [ __ ] Hillary
include Bernie who then [ __ ] endorsed
Hillary oh it's like that why would I do
that because your credit bloody right it
might be Bernie she was endorsing but
it's that thing that they say that's
just not true
what it is it's two factors one there's
a lot this the less hours women tend to
work less hours they also tend to take
risk guns and less easy well it just
kids something else Park choking just
maternity leave one's left
there's maternity leaves a bunch of
their factors they're less crazy less
ambitious they don't have as much
testosterone obviously they're not it's
[ __ ] crazy man who'd be willing to
work themselves into the grave and when
they're working side-by-side doing the
same job there's almost no disparity at
all there's a few jobs where men get
paid more than women but it's not much
and it's certainly not 70 cents to the
dollar and this is one thing that gets
touted out over and over again by people
but it's just not true i anointed look I
had a friend of mine who I got an
argument about it we was talking about
divorce where we were talking about a
buddy of ours that got [ __ ] in a
divorce and he goes hey maybe it's to
make up for the fact that women only
make 70 cents an hour ago okay the fact
that you say that drives me [ __ ]
crazy because you think it's a good
point don't yet he goes yeah I go do you
ever research that he goes no but it's a
fact like it's not a fact it's not a
fact they make 70 cents
comparing she said yes a guy said this
he's a guy he likes to argue he's a
friend of mine who likes to argue he's
got those guys oh you think he just got
yeah you gotta walk away from that no
he's a good guy he's a good guy but he's
got a [ __ ] problem
he doesn't like when he doesn't know
something and when he doesn't know
something he doesn't go holy [ __ ] really
he goes that's not true I don't what the
[ __ ] it's true
it's [ __ ] true like go google it like
you got a big [ __ ] grass your
webseries I want to watch you guys drive
from here to San Francisco just watching
you losing your [ __ ] it's [ __ ] true
look couple times we've gotten in these
arguments we've gotten in like three of
them it's like I when I'm not when I
don't know something I'll say I don't
know or if someone says something and I
didn't know that I'll go holy [ __ ] is
that true he's the opposite he's like
that's not true so if I don't know
something I'll do a bit on it twice
twice this [ __ ] guy's done the same
side yeah like I know what I'm talking
about
but I might get a bit on the wage gap of
my new uh no miner special yeah
well there you go won't fit my old thing
was like how the [ __ ] did they find out
what everybody makes you just call up
the IRS can we get that he tunes on
everybody they're gonna give me that
information uh well I don't know I don't
I haven't I know I did but all I know is
what it is harder for them straight
across the board that is the Pfirman
just everything is harder and all of our
lives are easier that's the all [ __ ]
message you say you're being sarcastic I
am NOT just like I you have one of my
favorite jokes of all time without uh
motherhood being what the hardest job of
the world he goes House is the hardest
job in the world when you wearing
[ __ ] pajamas all day yeah no job you
can do in your pajamas I love that bit
my wife hates it
no no I'm not saying it's not [ __ ] no
but it's fun [ __ ] oh yeah it's obviously
difficult but it's a funny place to
whole thing yeah go work on an oil rig
that [ __ ] blows up exactly as you
jump into the [ __ ] like on fire water
going underneath that and then you're
just sitting there with second-degree
burns and salt [ __ ] water hoping that
coastguard get stay before the shark
eats your life I'm talkin about you talk
to me about the terrible twos I have a
friend of mine who works at a oil rig in
Canada in northern Alberta work it's 50
below zero and I go how do you do it
they work outside I go how do you do it
he goes well you keep the truck running
and you work for about seven to ten
minutes at a time and you have to go
inside the truck for about a half an
hour I go really
he goes yeah he goes you can't take any
more because any exposed skin you have
you try to cover your face up as much as
possible you put a ski mask on but just
your eyes just all around your eyes is
all [ __ ] up like everything's [ __ ]
up it's like it's just too cold you just
can't do it
50 below zero they just work for short
stretches of time then they go in the
car and then the other guy will go out
while he's in there and then he'll go
out for like 10 minutes and then they
take a break for another 10-15 minutes
then they like the first guy will go
back out again yeah all of those shows
make me so thankful that I'm a comedian
those [ __ ] crab-fishing shows the
[ __ ] worst job you had as far as
physically like like I will kill myself
perform 30 if I [ __ ] do this out of
high school I worked on a there was a
Knights of Columbus Hall that was having
a wheelchair ramp built and I had to
carry cement bags and pressure-treated
lumber every day and I only lasted a
little over two weeks I think I lasted
eight days I was a gofer on a
construction site route we were roofing
in June or July oh and I just remember
having to bring up those first of all I
brought the wrong I bought the wrong
color [ __ ] shingles they wanted the
[ __ ] evany one and this was off a BAM
what the [ __ ] it was so I had to go all
the way back unload the [ __ ] things I
load it on load some more back brought
the [ __ ] things back I just remember
dude it was just like I never ate so
much in my life like I'd eat like three
sandwiches and like a half hour later
I'd be like starving and then weight was
just falling off of me I was just like
dude what the [ __ ] this is insane and
but the thing was if I hung in there for
like a month I would have got my sea
legs but I I just was like no but I
didn't have it I knew it I always knew I
always knew like when I play drums and
everything like that as much everytime I
thought I was getting good I go into
Guitar Center and some eight-year-old
kid would get on a kid I'd be like holy
[ __ ] like I was like dude I would pay
you to give me lessons it's just like
that when you switch when whatever
you're trying to do when you see like a
kid come in and he [ __ ] blow I mean
blows you away it's just like it's just
like I I this is this is a hobby bill
this is a hobby
well he's not working doing construction
is definitely not a [ __ ] hobby it's
just brutal but as a kid Labor Day zinc
is it's there's a gift as far as like
seeing how things
go to get all ya do there's an art to
everything political Louise showcase of
[ __ ] contractors okay no I mean as far
as building houses but I mean laboring
like carrying bags of cement isn't
[ __ ] art carrying bags of cement but
no but they would give me [ __ ] to do
like you know make this [ __ ] miter
cut for you and I [ __ ] the same cut up
three times in a row it was to frame a
door jamb and I kept measuring to the
inside of the corner rather the outside
of the corner remember that's third time
I did it that my boss just looked at me
grabbed the wood and he looked at me the
whole time walked up to the frame and
never never took his eyes off me the
frame was behind him he just stuck it to
the [ __ ] wall and just stared at me I
was so embarrassed I was just like god
dude he's like dude you're going you
went through like [ __ ] twenty dollars
with the stock to make one one [ __ ]
cut like what are you doing here I was
just like a analysis not even pissed
like a show I didn't pick up my check I
drove up to the site I work Monday
through Friday and then Monday Tuesday
Wednesday I drove up to the site and I
just looked at it and my body everything
just said dude [ __ ] this and I just kept
driving he never called why would he
call me I'm the guy waste and lumber he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he got free labor
out of me and I didn't give a [ __ ] and I
forget what I did after that but that
was a rough time for me but like I
always knew like if I'd if I didn't like
a job and stuff like that see it's like
the dinero thing and uh was at the heat
you got to be willing to walk in any
moment you got to be willing to [ __ ]
walk you got to know it's bad yeah that
was it that was the probably the
toughest physical job that I had and it
was also but good it was a good lesson
because it was a lesson that like if you
work for somebody else and you're just
doing labor you're just doing just
mindless labor you don't have any time
for anything else you think you got
eight hours in a day and there's still
another 16 you'll get [ __ ] done you're
exhausted you're [ __ ] beaten down I
would go to the gym I try to work out
and I remember trying to hit the bag and
I just had nothing there was nothing
that I'd never felt so tired in my life
yeah I was only like 18 I should have
been full of piss and vinegar I was just
dead and I remember like all my ambition
wheels would just ramp it up I was like
okay this is not my [ __ ] future I got
to figure out what the [ __ ] I'm doing
said I had these delusions that I was
going to become a carpenter I was like
wow
getting the Union
and I'll start building houses that's a
good gig which it is you know if your
that's what I thought I was going to do
yeah you know what it's a good gig if
you're the guy telling the people to go
build the [ __ ] house but if you're
the guy out there pouring the forms you
notice that that's mostly young guys
like that is a [ __ ] young even like
landscaping like after a while you got
to get a crew and you got to be the
guide like sending the crews out because
there's only so long that you can just
in a like I feel like like laborers and
that they have like the same career
trajectory as like a professional
athlete somewhere around 35 to 38 your
body's gonna be like dude I can't I
can't I can't [ __ ] do this anymore
you just break down there was a I had a
bulging disc in my neck and I went to an
MRI place and there was a lady who went
in before me lady waiting and this uh
lady I was looking at different people's
MRIs and this lady had the most [ __ ]
ridiculous cartoon bulge of her disk
some poor woman who I think she worked
in a laundromat or something like that
just carrying baskets of clothes and her
back was she is so [ __ ] up and she was
probably like 40 years old or something
like that came over here from you know
Mexico or Guatemala or something and I
remember looking at her back like in it
like this poor lady has no choice she
has to go to work there's no way around
this and there's no jobs for her other
than this you know like what she she
can't speak English she's got to do what
the [ __ ] she's got to do and she had you
went into her chart huh he started
reading right there
it was just sitting up there on the
screen now and I asked a guy who's back
his hat he goes it's hers I holy [ __ ] I
was mine like that bad heals no he goes
that's bad he goes that's bad it's real
bad like she could barely walk like she
had sciatica up and down her leg oh I
had that yeah well that's what that it
like what sciatica is a bulging disc is
a disc that's pressing against the
nerves
you had it would you do about it I went
to masseuse that helped oh yeah she
actually she works on I'll she's a
magician dude she started with like I
came in who she started with but went
how it came through me was through my
drum teacher so it was like MMA people
okay and then uh you know the whole some
drummer or guitarist or something was
into MMA
[ __ ] up something and he say go to my
masseuse and then she got all the
musicians with like that the tendinitis
and all that [ __ ] the forearms and then
it came around to me through my drum
teacher and now she seems like mate like
my left side was [ __ ] up like the left
leg and she started with my right
shoulder because your right shoulders
compensating for your left side yeah so
she was doing the whole I let's try to
get some information you know see what's
going on here and then she'd do
something I just go like yeah and she'd
be like she just be like she's good okay
there's some information all right and
then scale of one to ten the pain a dude
like um she what she did for me like
literally she went so [ __ ] deep it
was like these memories come out I mean
my brother you should just give me
charley horses and [ __ ] for no [ __ ]
reason you remembered it yeah like it
was a store no no like the pain of it
like just pops up I just I wouldn't be
like literally thinking and you just
have the thought like yeah my brother
he's always kicked me in the [ __ ] leg
day and there was another one I remember
I was playing pick-up hockey and I had
no stuff all I had was the [ __ ] the
the helmet and the gloves in the skate
had like sweatpants in like a [ __ ]
t-shirt or whatever and I'm out there
like an [ __ ] and I've you know going
down the ice and all this on the other
team gets it so I pop over to [ __ ]
start skating backwards I caught an edge
and just went up in the air and just
landed on my left ass cheek and [ __ ]
that whole side dude I landed so [ __ ]
hard like I couldn't breathe and my eyes
were watering it's like literally been
when you're skating it's like being
thrown out of a moving car right so I
got up and everyone was laughs and I
[ __ ] up my elbow
you know it's hockey see just fine you
know I get to the bench and I was fine
and a couple shifts later it kind of
worked itself out and I bruised my legs
so bad it was like three days later I
was on the road and I was showering or
something I just saw on the side of my
leg it looked like I had sat in grease
or something and I that I looked all the
way the back of my leg it looked like
someone took a pipe and just had [ __ ]
whacked me as hard as you could across
the back of my leg it was at this
straight [ __ ] line and I think my
sciatic nerve thing was which is a
culmination of all of that [ __ ] and then
there was that last thing that did it so
she [ __ ] worked all the way out of
that
gave me all these stretches and I found
like a good chiropractor and all that
and it's all good now yeah I'll do it I
gonna show you a [ __ ] I couldn't even
sit down because of my feet were stuck
would start to tingle and stuff what
numbness is way worse than that's beyond
pain is what I heard so the numbness
thing is worth so she goes all right
we're going to work you from numbness
down to pain and then pain hopefully
down to that and I just I just started
going every [ __ ] week but I got a
machine I have to show you it's called a
reverse hyper answer machine that
decompresses your back while
strengthening it it's you lift weights
with it you lift your legs up and then
it strengthens your back and then as you
live you live I know this [ __ ] well I
work for the Ultimate Fighting
Championship I mean I've been in a legit
for every time I get this [ __ ]
chamber right attention to stuff I mean
that's what I do
I have been in tension to the wrong [ __ ]
I've been doing martial arts and tells a
little kid I mean maintaining your body
is a big part of that it's one of the
most difficult parts of martial arts is
not getting injured all the time your
Khan because martial arts are all about
hurting people
so that's practicing hurting each other
so like you have to find good partners
there's always that guy in class that I
was too [ __ ] hard there's always that
that's Charlie Murphy talking about that
guy yeah as a big problem Charlie sent
me and I only lasted a couple weeks of
the dojo my [ __ ] ad deal I maybe I
learn how to cook now if you know I just
I'd left so I never which I was just
like I his deal you're gonna go down
there when was this Oh back we doing the
rich-bitch tour really yeah he was you
were doing much what kind of martial
arts renown whatever style he has his
[ __ ] black dude I only I only lasted
like two weeks
I [ __ ] I actually took jujitsu with
Dom fig did you real in the late 90s I
lasted like five weeks of doing that
actually did I right I did all right but
then the guy teaching he couldn't speak
English and this lady like dislocated
like her [ __ ] ribcage can something
[ __ ] up happen and he didn't know what
to do and I just remembered like you
know it's coming home with bruises and
[ __ ] it was like that was like when
pilot season you could actually get on
something and I was just like the [ __ ]
am i doing why don't I make enough money
where I have security actually get on
something funny remember development
deals yeah and [ __ ] could actually
happened and you go to Montreal and get
it
then you be set I just member the guy
who will skip the hip it's like this ah
no good it's like this ah is good that
was the whole [ __ ] class punching
easier like these no like this escape
hip escape mm yes keep the hip whatever
the [ __ ] he was saying and you know I
learned some [ __ ] I still know if I'm on
my back how to get somebody into an arm
bar but it's probably well it's probably
I look at martial arts it's like comedy
so like I think that that worked in the
late 90s but now that would be like a
corny joke now and I think like that
movie I'm going to [ __ ] try that like
an eight-year-old knows how to get out
of it like you're funny at the office
you think you're going to go kill at the
Ryman Auditorium Yeah right that's the
difference yeah it's more like a time
thing we're like that was probably
state-of-the-art [ __ ]
whatever we state of the art then that
mean you talk to drama god I was like 18
years ago
there's no [ __ ] about that move
everybody knows that moves it's like
playing drums well actually all the
standard old school moves are Brazilian
Jujitsu are still good they're all still
good if you're good at like there's some
guys that are really good at what you
call basic is a weird lassard's yeah
basics a weird word and people get upset
when you say they're jujitsu is very
basic but some of the best guys ever
have what you call basic jujitsu it's
not that it's basic it's just they have
only a small amount of moves that they
use but they have them sharpen to a
razor's edge and it's not that they not
they're not capable of doing everything
else just some guys like there's guys
that are known for just having a
guillotine choke that's all they do
and you just got to avoid that [ __ ]
guillotine choke and they might still
get you with it
some guys they just win by triangle all
the time only by triangle and this guy's
only win by he'll hook there's like a
bunch of that [ __ ] that kuszak the
California kid Urijah Faber oh dude that
guy's hilarious did you see when he was
on The Ultimate Fighter sure okay that
thing that he when he gave that kid [ __ ]
early on when he was trying to make the
show uh-huh and whatever he got caught
and pick a move whatever the [ __ ]
rear naked choke or something like that
and then when the kid went the kid goes
in and he loses
rear naked choke and as he went out like
Uriah just goes like yeah he goes that's
what he's known for
look him up and what I loved about that
it was like old school parenting yet no
[ __ ] sympathy it's just like and I
thought was very empowering
thing to do to that person like I feet
once he got past the defeat like you'd
be sitting there going like yeah what
the [ __ ] you know that this is what the
guy did let him beat you with anything
else but that that's so easy and this is
on me it's so much easier said than done
it's it's it's incredibly difficult to
stop someone is really good at something
if they're really good at I don't think
I'd have a problem Joe I rented the last
28 boxer what's the what was we got we
got a wrap-up I do buying an hour here
so like uh give me all all things Joe
Rogan where we can see you any UFC
things coming up he we talked earlier
this is giant one giant one in Madison
Square Garden because the UFC was
illegal in New York for 19 years and it
was all because of corruption this is a
funny story the culinary Union the guys
who used to own the UFC they sold the
UFC but the guys who used to own the UFC
also own station casinos they own Red
Rocks and they owned a bunch of
different casinos like I think 22
separate casinos maybe even more and all
their casinos were non-union and this is
a vote by the the casino themselves like
they got paid well and I guess they just
decided look we don't we don't need to
be Union so the culinary union was
trying to muscle the owners of the UFC
into going Union and so the way they
would do it is then they have a bunch of
different things they do they'll stand
out and the culinary Union is drunk
they're huge they're huge and they got
those knives they managed to keep the
UFC out of New York and then one of the
guys it was in their pocket got arrested
for corruption he was the main guy that
was keeping the UFC out in New York he
went down last year at a corruption and
right after he went down they passed it
in New York State because it was passed
in every city and they they told the
public that it was all that human
cockfighting exactly I mean while they
had cake boxing boxing everything else
was legal but they wouldn't let the UFC
in and so finally it's legal now and now
that it's legal and also there's new
owners so the culinary Union doesn't
have a beef with these new owners
because they don't even have any casinos
and the the new event that they're going
to put in Madison Square Garden has
three
world title fights for former world
champions three different fighters were
fought for the title before I mean it's
a [ __ ] unbelievable stacked car
raising the greatest card in this fight
Conor McGregor's fighting Eddie Alvarez
it's a it's a - - there's three title
fights but there's two champions in the
in the final Conor is the featherweight
champion Eddie Alvarez is a lightweight
champion and if Connor wins will be the
first guy to hold two titles
simultaneously in the UFC how do you get
in that Conor McGregor shape is it too
late for me at 48 no no you can do it
too boy he's just I can't no come on I'm
gonna give you a pill I'm gonna give you
an ass I'm gonna give you a mindset I'm
gonna teach you take the mindset you
can't tell you're just [ __ ] with oh
you think
no I thought I would hope I had [ __ ]
hope he's getting great shape he's
liking [ __ ] remember Tommy Hearns hmm
like that level shredded where Tommy was
like a six foot tall [ __ ]
middleweight yeah somehow he could make
like what is middleweight 140 well he
was 147 when he fought Sugar Ray Leonard
was welterweight it was Ronnie yeah
unbelievable he was just like just like
it was like you drew him yeah like how
do you get that [ __ ] shred had that
tiny waist and big broad shoulders and a
ridiculous right hand Pat reach him but
when he knocked out uh Roberto ran
that's what is sick it was a hook right
I think it was a right hand he
face-planted them I think him with a
bunch of things but I think he hit him
with he dropped him twice but then he
faceplant on with a right hand where
Duran just felt like a tree yeah that
was like Pacquiao death yes exactly like
Marquez
so um Conor McGregor is not in the best
shape this is what's interesting I mean
he's obviously in great shape but he's
got a problem with his endurance it's
one of the things that makes this fight
interesting like he got tired I heard
you saying because he has explosive
movements he uses up a lot of energy
he's so [ __ ] fast he's so fast and so
explosive that when you have that style
of fighting
it's like sprinting whereas Nate Diaz
the guy fought was more of like a
marathon runner like Nate I love Nate
Nate's awesome and so is brother Nick
but their style is more like they don't
go 100% they don't use a hundred percent
of their energy with every punch they're
more like 60s maybe 70% and they're
always they're always fresh and they do
a lot of marathon running they do a lot
of try
Ethel ons and they're always doing the
endurance work so the their endurance is
a big part of their ability to recover
and push a pace that most people can't
survive from so Conor is not that guy
conscious when he was like Nate Diaz
like towards the end he did a lot of
looking at the clock did all the running
away - yeah had a reset you ran it
literally ran away from him and reset
and you know it's smart that reminded me
once when I first did stand-up and Steve
sweetie was late and I was on a material
and I just kept looking at the back door
lazy common is he coming I got nothing
to live I remember those days
he'll I don't that was at the Brockton
the Brockton Knicks comedy stop member
then you stood up on that like I was
like looking you know those awful stages
where it was a really small stage like a
giant so he was standing on top of a
[ __ ] refrigerator for whatever reason
and you're like looking down on the
people it was almost like this Andy
Kaufman like talk show desk but it was
the stage I don't know if I did Brockton
I don't know if I did the Kowloon I've
never gone by then it might have been
gone I did I did the the Randolph I did
Brockton Framingham and then I think
that was it for the Knicks and then
there was of course the one downtown I
never did Framingham either I don't
think I think that was gone all Kowloon
of course the Lawrence did the Kowloon I
did giggles my Clark's room did you ever
do to out giggles hundred one crocodilly
and so anyway the Conor McGregor thing
like he's not I would say he's not the
best cardio in the world you can't say
he's not in great shape because he did
go five rounds with Nate Diaz but it
just it's not he's not the same kind of
shape feel like like Nick Diaz has swam
from Alcatraz five times gets in the
[ __ ] ocean with shark infested
Northern California waters sweatin and
that you have to be in incredible shape
to divvy out of your [ __ ] mind to
that too but you got to be an incredible
shape I got a buddy of mine I just got
done running the Big Foot 200
he ran 204 [ __ ] miles 205 205 miles
in 78 hours three days of running three
and a half three days and [ __ ] wanker
spoken word
yep it's called the Big Foot 200 it's
all document it's like running 60 to 70
miles a day oh yeah yeah yeah you're
less than that 50 yeah something like
that yeah something like that
numbers yeah 70 is 21 say 63 about 63 I
like what you saying
after Adrienne I I like it 18 yeah he
he's run hundreds a couple of times he
actually ran a hundred in June to
prepare for the 200 in August crazy so
his half marathon is a hunt his four
marathons basically he's a [ __ ]
animal I mean he runs up does he does he
run with those feet sneakers no we can
see the toes
now he's sponsored by Under Armour so he
wears the Under Armour Fat Tire shoes
it's a nice cushiony shoe but he's uh he
will run fourteen fifty miles a day
every day who came up with that big foot
two hundred savages [ __ ] barbarians
name's Cameron Haynes he's a
professional bow hunter and to get in
shape for bow hunting his bow hunting is
all about like climbing up mountains and
[ __ ] especially when you're hunting elk
hunt with that guy and it's [ __ ]
exhausting I'm in pretty good shape not
in great shape I'm pretty good shape I
could barely keep up with him I mean
barely he's barely out of breath and I'm
[ __ ] dying I'm drenched in sweat
eaving and trying to follow it cuz like
well you don't have bring your line for
that one or anybody else I mean the way
he does it is a very unique he's like
one of the most successful elk hunters
in the world and one of the reasons is
his shape because he can get to places
like you see an elk and the elk goes
over the ridge the key is you got to get
to that [ __ ] elk quickly because it's
moving over that Ridge
right so if you if you're looking at an
elk and it goes over the top of a hill
and goes to the other side the quicker
you can get to that the closer it's
going to be that hill you got to get
within sixty yards and you don't know
how how far it's going to move in the
time it takes you to get up there well
it takes me maybe ten minutes to get up
there he'll take him two minutes so but
in those extra eight minutes the [ __ ]
Alex way out of range you go down the
hill after it's gonna see you you're
never gonna get a shot at it so he has
rematch I'm up shot opportunity do you
have any like like the one that got away
sort of shot like you had it you lined
it up and whatever you exhaled it the
wrong time and you missed it then it
took off that's an elk hunting you so
there I had five of those two weeks ago
there's five of those at least maybe six
we hunted for I shot that one with a
rifle because we just couldn't get close
enough with a bow just five do you feel
your guide going like dude you're gonna
[ __ ] kill one here
more pressure oh that's just how it is
elk hunting is hard you know when you go
and earn when are you gonna go wild boar
hunting again I'm going with you
you and I are gonna go we're gonna
schedule something soon we'll schedule
something let's schedule something like
maybe after Christmas yeah get me an Uzi
and then I'm gonna I'm gonna get you yes
ah is it comes running because those
think I saw when saying they're watching
the chef they're from Hell's Kitchen
god damn and I said his name early I'm
the worst yeah Gordon Ramsay you made
his scrambled eggs again this morning my
wife [ __ ] loves him what kind of
scrambled AC oh dude he [ __ ] he puts
this what he does he first of all he
gets he gets the pepper pot a little pan
going a little olive oil put some tomato
still on the vine there with some
mushrooms he just lets that [ __ ]
sizzle and then he takes three eggs and
like a dollop of [ __ ] butter puts it
in there doesn't mix it already puts it
on the flame and then he starts mixing
this thing around he talks about all the
chemistry you don't want to mix it
before you put it in there doesn't put
any salt in there because some reason
that does it he's like on a Heath now
off to hate see there and yet do it
because they hate it's in here I watched
it a zillion [ __ ] times when I'm
watching this he heats in the pan hates
in the pan so that's the one thing that
I learned I learned from this guy chef
Roy who did uh Roy Troy who started the
whole gourmet food truck thing I did
like Favreau's doing shooting this thing
and I went over there and I got to city
taught me this [ __ ] about the grilled
cheese sandwich and what I learned about
these guys is dude it's all controlling
the heat like my host [ __ ] is just like
medium high I'm like medium high for ten
minutes it's like you're not cooking you
just stand-in there like a [ __ ]
bouncer or some [ __ ] it's like so he got
emulated so he does all of that and when
it gets to a certain level of uh coming
together then he takes his creme fraiche
and puts it in there what is creme
fraiche I don't know what the [ __ ] it is
but it's delicious right and then you
get it you bring it back back on the
heat and insult in right he puts that
[ __ ] in you go you just keep stirring
this [ __ ] thing and it almost looks
like it's water you don't think it's
done you tasting like oh my god this is
great then you take it off right no wait
you chop up a little bit of dill you
sprinkle it up you mix it in there and
then the by then the sourdough toast
pops up a little olive oil on that he
put the [ __ ] scrambled eggs on that
with the [ __ ] tomatoes and the
mushroom
give it to your wife over well over but
then they love it and then they keep
telling you to make it he just like
let's just do the old scrambled egg with
the cheese in it I got to get you some
eggs we have our own chickens I have 23
chickens now how long can they lay eggs
before you have to [ __ ] retirement
well they just stopped laying eggs after
a while but in you swing right no I just
let them live they just they just live
and then they die though I've had a
bunch just die he'll die I've had
chickens for now I want to say five
years somewhere around there four or
five years maybe five years and they
just [ __ ] die sometimes I've had like
but I have some of them that are like
five years old that are still five years
old I just picture this chicken at his
desk
you know the seminal classic 1950s heart
attack you know back then when nobody
knew [ __ ] about [ __ ] heart attacks it
was terrifying why does everybody's
hearts just [ __ ] stop and they were
all eating bacon and [ __ ] martinis
and all this [ __ ] I had no idea and that
was back when they you know they had no
respect from martial arts it was all I
got Talia Nelson's stronger than a good
old Sunday punch and they'd be sit there
eating [ __ ] steaks and people were
just dropping their light and left like
dropping dead I know you like when
conspiracy theories you like a good
conspiracy theories but I like a good
one
the good I don't like Sorokin here's the
silly ones isn't like one lumped in with
people who have silly understand that
here's a real why don't we move in it
was in the New York Times they prove
that scientists were paid off by the
sugar industry in the 1960s oh yeah
absolutely
they were paid off to make saturated fat
the culprit for all these diseases and
fat fat people and heart attacks when it
was actually sugar I'm 11 trying to
steal the blame away from sugar and pin
it on saturated fat so babies scientists
bacon is actually not bad for you
saturated fat is actually not bad for
you there's a giant illusion that
cholesterol everybody thinks to collect
all your cholesterol is high dietary
cholesterol barely moves the needle on
blood lipids blood lip it's like when
they measure your diet when you bet
measure cholesterol your blood has to do
with a lot of sounds great to me but
you're also a stand-up comedian you
don't outline you don't have a white lab
coat on
like okay dr. Rogan you read breezy
thing what good what gives people high
cholesterol is first of all the LDL
cholesterol HDL cholesterol is good
cholesterol and bad cholesterol and you
can have high of wamba's if you have
higher the other one it balances each
other out I'll send you a podcast if you
have the [ __ ] the time to listen to
it it's a concise you can [ __ ] sit
there long enough you ferret it's hard
it's hard it's hard to sit down and
listen to this stuff but this guy Chris
crushers on my podcast who explained it
all in behind one of the great names of
all time Chris Kresser Kris
Kristofferson
hang on a sec Chris crasher scar oh um
but anyway it's not cholestacare teri
look if you have high blood pressure or
dietary cholesterol or high David
Letterman Dave lemon let me do an ounce
of fat on him and he needed open-heart
surgery yes yeah yeah a lot of that's
hereditary some people just get a [ __ ]
roll the dice just like some kids are
born with leukemia I mean just a sound
something you did so like I've been
smoking since there were a fetus you
know my big Fitness thing is I'm big
time into body weight oh yeah buddy
exercises so I'm trying to get myself
strong enough to do a front lever it
[ __ ] 48 years away from the front
lever is basically you hang from the
chin up are you bring your legs straight
up and you hang in there like a [ __ ]
table and you got to put partyi weight
behind the bar so there's all of these
exercises to explain that okay so it's
all you eat just mad mad you know
do you remember planking yes just
imagine if you did it on your back
you're laying on your back in the air
but you're hanging from the chin apart
and the legs are straight out like that
okay yeah so I've been [ __ ] with that
for like months trying to build up the
strength and I got myself to the point
cuz the whole thing is you got to be
behind the bar right and what's great is
I got this big head so kind of [ __ ]
you know there's a lot of weight already
behind the bar but so I've got him a
point now where I can actually like I
used to be almost hanging upside down
and then gradually you can kind of bring
you have your legs in a ball so like the
weight is basically underneath and I've
gotten to the point now or I can just
start to extend one leg and then I fall
to the ground ain't bad I'm gonna get
there though
you'll get there I just want to bust
that out one time because I got a buddy
woman he has a bet with me that when I'm
70 I can't do 10 pull-ups why so just to
[ __ ] 70 nope
when I turned 772 m to catch the better
just keep going you get that's the thing
Stallone's in the 70s yeah but if I
don't set he could do 10 push-ups right
so the chin-ups if I don't have that bet
and I don't have that [ __ ] so it's a
great carrot that I'm chasing there I
understand yeah
you could do that has nothing to do with
age you could do that move shangela does
it have to do with butter do bacon and
[ __ ] like that lifting just get a you
know the best way to do it honestly
start doing bodyweight exercises do a
lot of chin-ups and stuff like that but
do them really slowly that's one of the
best ways to really develop like serious
strength like a lot of people like to do
chin-ups they like to do those like
kipping chin-ups you see in CrossFit
what I like to do is what skipping like
ego like you kind of like kick up and
you kick up and everything that's like a
cheating it is like cheating but it's
people who octave back on the exact
price but it's a hard workout if you do
a bunch of them but it's just there's a
lot of criticism why does CrossFit have
to be done in front of everybody why
can't they just stay in their gym why
are they always running up and down the
street like look at us we're working out
cuz it's like look at us we're working
out shiny mall the church nope nope you
should rub it in their face they're like
vegans in a lot of ways I want you to
know what they're doing you know it's
like that like that's that that's part
of the whole thing it's like you become
there's a whole article about that about
its replacing religion for a lot of
people they become tribal and you get
involved in these group like group
activities and you you identify with
that group like you could come across
better or you become a vegan or you
become a lot I mean not this anything
wrong with people well I won it was like
the gym is a good garage Jordan wide
open they're making all this [ __ ]
noise and it's like yet I work out too
you know what I have the door closed
listen to a little Iron Maiden lately
but that's part of the fun of it they
want everybody to know they're doing it
so you walk by a while Billy's in shape
you know look at that look at him he's
[ __ ] lift and he's do I've been like
I've been honest haven't breakfast like
outside cafe and all some twenties
maniacs just run by get to the corner
and then they run back the other way you
just want to [ __ ] throw your pancakes
out well it's worse what if you're
walking and they they [ __ ] almost run
you over like hey [ __ ] this is not a
gym okay this is a sidewalk like don't
this is not there's not a place for you
to conduct your class maybe it's like
it's doing anything like they think the
treadmills take up too much energy
No
I think you're right so they want people
to know what they're doing they don't
have the space that you know they'd have
a track so they decide to use a sidewalk
you know I've seen that I've seen like
groups of people run up and down streets
it's [ __ ] stupid
it's outdoes in Santa Monica I was
[ __ ] laughing my handsome stupid sit
there and look at mountains but CrossFit
itself what it does is it gets people to
get competitive and when they get
competitive the good thing about it is
like there's a bunch of people around
you you're all pushing each other the
bad thing about it is a lot of people
their form falls apart when they start
doing high repetitions and they get
competitive with it and they start
getting injured I know a lot of [ __ ]
people that have hurt themselves doing
Crossfit a lot of bells people always
[ __ ] themselves up right behind in there
baby yeah I don't [ __ ] with crap on
those these can do them slowly and doing
with correct form the beautiful thing
about kettlebells is you can get a great
workout with a light kettlebell I could
get a great workout with a 35-pound
kettlebell just like kettlebell moving
it slowly controlling in every step of
the way and you can do all sorts of
exercises go from one to the other one
the other and you give up you get a full
body workout that works it's actual
functional strength like it'll apply
that leaving the reservation with I'm
going all old-school I got those atomic
holds you like that American ninja [ __ ]
those little [ __ ] look like little
cannon balls so great I got those
hanging from my ceiling and I'm trying
to get the ones that look like the
nunchuck handles and I [ __ ] went to
order the thing and it never came and
then they sent me an email going like
did you still want them it's like yeah I
order to go to rogue fitness rogue
fitness comm they have all that crazy so
you got that sure that's what I my rack
through those guys okay and I got a
speed bag and then I'm gonna get those
Swedish blasts and see if I can get it
myself up to be able to do a [ __ ]
human flag oh [ __ ] well I like to [ __ ]
where I'm working towards something I
can't just get on an elliptical every
day like I'm doing a half hour and the
big thing is what's my new playlist cuz
I will get bored shitless with that but
I feel like with the speed bag you know
I suck at that but I'm getting a little
bit better at it like I say I'm like
learning some I you know it's funny my
wife wanted it I wasn't man enough I
didn't want to have think but look at it
yeah it's something cool about doing it
but do you know like julio cesar chavez
didn't even know how to do that it's
kind of useless for boxing it gives you
a little bit endurance for your
shoulders but
the [ __ ] class how much my dream
punch somebody like this imagine someone
stood in front of you punching like this
I think it was to build up it was
supposed to be timing and also build up
your arms you keep your arms I'll
shoulder and turns your head
Yeah right but Julio Cesar Chavez it's
hilarious his only greatest boxer of all
time he always used to laugh because he
would like try to do it and he couldn't
do it thank you then he could knock
everybody out in the [ __ ] everybody
I mean he's a [ __ ] monster listen
dude I'm Chum I'm just trying to get in
the eye I wish to go to Gleason's Gym
and they can they knew I was there and
they call me billary Swank you know cuz
look uh I'm milk millions millon Million
Dollar Baby it just come out Hillary's
we're loving Oh now we had a great time
Charlie Murphy once again gave me the
you gave me no gave me the lay of the
land Charlie goes you going down eggsy
ok he goes you're gonna be down there
about three weeks in a bad Charlie
Murphy it goes someone's gonna come up
to you be like oh how long you've been
boxing yo you nice mama why don't you
get in the ring I'm not getting the ring
yes he wants to go in there and try out
all the [ __ ] that he doesn't have the
nerve to try against a professional
fighter and you're gonna get [ __ ] up
right exactly three weeks whatever [ __ ]
he said on the nose
this [ __ ] this guy comes up black
dude from Brooklyn starts coming to a
white guy stand-up comedian from the
suburbs go yo you nice man you can Fox I
just started laughing I got to get the
[ __ ] out of here I'm not getting the
ring with you when he [ __ ] laughed and
walked away and I told Charlie thinking
he would laugh you know Charlie's are so
[ __ ] real deal he just said I [ __ ]
told you it's like I told you Charlie
Murphy is one of the best guys of all
time I did that Maxim tour with him I
got to know him we did 22 dates together
yeah he's a [ __ ] great guy and I
really loved that dude I really you know
one of those guys my [ __ ] phone were
in the toilet I lost his [ __ ] number
so I didn't be able to call him I think
I got it I give to you ok yeah I love
that we got a rap to stop dude I'm
sitting like 9 million hours of traffic
Joe you're the [ __ ] best you've been
one of the top comics for what 20 25 I'm
we [ __ ] here since I was in Boston
when I saw you at the kowloon and you
did your Tigers [ __ ] bit which sounds
like oh it's just targets [ __ ]
through the distant noise you made of
the tiger was [ __ ] unbelievable I
still remember your bit making fun of
the chicks out there with the hair like
a giant
oh my god you're [ __ ] monster so I'm
so happy for you that you got another
special that's out on Netflix is called
triggered please watch it if you love it
please rate it so uh you know stay on
the front whatever that [ __ ]
scrolling thing is and and that's it man
you gonna hook me up with some elk meat
[ __ ] you right thanks but I really
appreciate you having me another word
another still the same way about you man
you're one of my all-time fish we're
gonna have a big hug after alright guys
thanks for listening alright what's up
bill burr here alright how great was
that ah the great Joe robe and finally
got him on after 9 years of doing my
[ __ ] podcast finally got him on and I
didn't do any of the advertising because
I knew that it was going to be too
interesting to sit there and talk to
that guy so here's a little bit of
advertising I know what you thinking oh
[ __ ] bill the [ __ ] advertising that's
boring well not the way I do it alright
here we go we got a new one here C so C
so se e so C so there you go [ __ ] you
man alright C so is the place for comedy
they won't tell you how amazing they are
but I will evidently C so is amazing its
comedy for comedy nerds by comedy nerds
C so spelt si eso se ESO is the new ad
free streaming service bringing you
hilarious original specials hand-picked
classics weeks of standard not [ __ ]
that my nan they're not pay me you [ __ ]
hand up pics can't pick classics weeks
of stand-up specials and more a bin
jabal kana big comedy anytime anywhere
see so every episode of SNL ever really
Jesus this is a big [ __ ] thing because
those guys those guys hoard those
specials those episodes including new
episodes the day after they air the
Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon Jimmy
Fallon from New England I get did so
great uh and Late Night with Seth Meyers
the day after they air and they even
have classics like thirty Rock Parks and
Recreation and Saved by the Bell
now those are already classics you see
Saved by the Bell even British comedies
the original office with that dangerous
guy ricky gervais Saul what's he gonna
do at the Emmys he's drinking a beer oh
he got a smoke a cigarette next the
entire Monty Python catalog the it crowd
and Steve Coogan
as Alan Partridge discover the next big
names in comedy and watch the icons
before they made it before they made it
big like louis c.k chelsea peretti Amy
Schumer Bo Burnham and so much more
critically acclaimed originals and
exclusive content like Harmon quest
created by comedian Dan Harmon and funny
as hell a variety show featuring such
comedians as Jim Jeffries ah Jim
Jeffries and Hannibal Buress if you're
serious about comedy you got to go to
see so stream at any time Jesus [ __ ]
Christ we get it see so is ad-free and
it's just 399 a month that's less than
you paid for the latte or artisan cold
brewed coffee you're holding right now
and right now my listeners can try see
so free for two months when you use
promo code bird at the checkout at any
point they're going to say what see so
stands for C so um seriously ignorant
egos [ __ ] Oscars I don't [ __ ]
shows what you can get in shows you
can't get anywhere else from critically
acclaimed original series to all 40 plus
years of SNL see so it's the only place
that offers every episode ever made and
the new episodes the day after they air
just go to see so calm right now to sign
up for too much for free for promo with
the promo code burrowed check out that C
SOCOM promo code BRR dude just for the
[ __ ] SNL alone that's great all right
hey speaking of Joe Rogan here's his
company on it on it has a new product
it's called emulsified MCT oil what the
[ __ ] is that well we're going to tell
you MCT oil is one of the fastest
sources of clean fuel for the body and
the brain it's one of the best ways to
power up your performance and kickstart
a weight management program and I should
do that rub it right on my stomach there
are a lot of MCT oil brands out there
but none there's none like the
emulsified MCT oil from on it
what's emulsification that's like when
you got balsamic vinaigrette just
sitting there okay and the [ __ ]
vinaigrette goes away from the balsamic
or vice versa or whatever and you [ __ ]
freakin up and all of a sudden it's been
combined it's been emulsified you get it
it's like a carburetor when you got the
air in the fuel mixture and it creates
that foam that you can't drink but it
looks like a latte
that's emulsification emulsification
available in three delicious flavors
coconut vanilla and strawberry Jesus
Christ that's me right there coconut
head vanilla skin strawberry pubes
emulsified MCT oil mixes like a cream
easily in your morning coffee without
the need for a blender no mess no
cleanup you can even mix it into your
favorite food liquid Billy red face
right here from on it right now if you
go to on accom onn IT comm slash burger
you can get on it's emulsified MCT oil
for 12% off that's on it Oh n n8 e
dot-com slash burr to get emulsified MCT
oil for 12% off any and for any reason
if you don't like it they'll give you
money back no questions asked you got
nothing to lose
go to on accom slash burn now and get
and get on it okay what again left Jesus
Christ I get out of breath from reading
out loud that's how dumb I am all right
seat geek
okay buying tickets online for sports
and concepts has been a confusing
process for a long time no there's
nothing confusing about it cause the
[ __ ] fortune it's always hard to find
the best deal for that game or show you
want to go to and none of those older
ticket sites want to change that but see
geek is different they've come along and
create an amazing app and website that
makes it easier for then F than ever for
fans to buy and sell tickets see geek
does all the price comparisons for you
by searching multiple ticket sites and
ensuring that you get the best possible
deal and see geek wants to help you get
the best move the best bang for your
buck that's why even ticket that's why
every ticket on Sikhi is given a grade
based on value you'll immediately see
any under priced seats and be able to
find the best deals that fit your budget
best of all my list is get $20 $20
rebate off their first
SeatGeek purchase to get you $20 rebate
on tickets how do I do that man
download the SeatGeek app go to the
settings tab and click Add and add a
promo code enter the promo code barbie
you are our c geek will send you $20 off
after you've made your first ticket
purchase download the seat geek app and
enter the promo code birt'day jesus i
was doing all right there oh jesus here
we go our old friends here everybody
here they are returning once again old
zip are you hiring are you hiring do you
know where to post your job to find the
best candidates posting your job in one
place ad isn't enough to find quality
candidates what do i do man if you want
to find the perfect hire you need to
post your job on all the top job sites
is it hard no it's easy with all [ __ ]
zip Crudup dot-com you can post your job
to 100 plus job sites including social
media networks like the facebook like
the twitter all with one single click
there
find candidate in front of candidate in
any in city or any industry what find
candidates in any city or industry
nationwide just post once and wash your
qualified candidates roll in like all
that hot border down rail in florida to
zip recruiters easy-to-use interface
no judging emails no juggling emails or
calls to your office quickly screen
candidates rate them and hire the right
person fast find out today why zip
dot-com has been used over one by over 1
million businesses and right now you my
listeners my listeners can post job on
zip rick for free by going free by going
to zip recruit accom / / that zip
recruiter comm / / one more time to get
free go to her sip rick grub third calm
/ / alright next one last and final
sorry that's getting obnoxious i know
but there's only so many with different
ways to read alright all jesus its track
we're all losers Newsweek reports the
average American wastes 55 minutes a day
looking for things they own but can't
find share a story when you've lost
something you needed yeah I lost my soul
when I [ __ ] do something like that
just give me the copy and I'll [ __ ]
read it oh yeah I remember the time I
couldn't find my mittens oh boy and we
had a snowball fight coming up I get it
you put this [ __ ] thing on [ __ ] you
don't lose it anymore yet for some
reason they're going to write 10 pages
of [ __ ] tracker makes losing things a
thing of the past and I'll tell you how
to get one for free in a minute tracker
is a coin size device that locates
misplaced keys wallets bags computers
dildos anything in seconds just pair
tracker to your smartphone attach it to
anything and find his precise location
with the tap of a button it's that easy
lose your phone press a button ah there
it is on track of your phone rings even
when it's on silent reaping tracker is
finding over a million Jesus Christ Cleo
could you go take a [ __ ] flea bath
even shaking and stirring the whole
[ __ ] time we're supposed to be at all
don't look at me like that come here
buddy come here I'm sorry you just look
at me like dude I will [ __ ] rip your
throat out if I want to now it's up on
the couch that's all that wanted good
good
all right trackers where my tracker is
finding over a million misplaced items
each day order yours and never lose
anything again listen to the show get a
free tracker Bravo with any order go to
thee th e tracker comm and enter promo
code ber the hardest thing you'll ever
have to find is their website go to
tracker comm right now and enter the
promo code BIR for free tracker what
free tracker Bravo with any order again
that's tracker comm promo code berm did
anybody see that [ __ ] ad on TV that
was making fun of Ohio State the way
they go the Ohio State University they
were talking about things they used that
you're sick up they go are you sick of
dramatic pauses after football players
say the name of the University and they
had this guy like doing like cross-eyed
and just went like the Brockton
Community College
i butchered it but you got to see it the
guy's performance on it is tremendous
it's as funny as how unfunny the way I
just did it look at you Cleo
what are you doing hmm you want to go
outside Cleo can I get her to howl
before we leave click get off the couch
get off the couch all right here we go
the key is you just have to make eye
contact I'm gonna go for this Cleo do
you want to go outside
Cleo there you go good girl all right
I'll talk to you later